Hello!
We know why you are here:
you think diffusion models are too slow and
you are tired of waiting for their unrushed
iterative generation process.
Are you asking yourself whether there is a
faster way than diffusion to do the same job?
Or are you happy to see us covering research
coming from normal academic teams, rather
than huge teams at OpenAI, Google or Meta,
DeepMind...?
Great, because no matter your reason for clicking
on this video, we’ve got you covered on
many fronts.
Today, we are going to explain how Paella
works, which is a new way to generate images
conditioned on text, without using diffusion
or transformers.
Paella runs faster than diffusion and arguably,
is conceptionally easier to understand than
diffusion.
It also comes from a normal academic team
supported by Stability AI with compute, though.
Also, Dominic, the first author of this paper
does great tutorials and explanations on YouTube,
do check out his channel, I’m sure you won’t
regret it.
Ok, so in this video, Ms. Coffee Bean will
give her best shot at explaining Paella.
But first, let’s thank Creative Fabrica,
the sponsor of today’s video!
Since you are here watching this video about
research in art generating models, we think
you might be interested to try out Creative
Fabrica Spark, an AI image generator that
creates images that are 100% unique!
Just look at this “whimsical ultra cute
grinch in fairytale landscape, pastel colors,
…” created by Stian Iversen.
Do you like what you see?
Great, because you can try it out yourself
for free or with a monthly $9 subscription.
If you choose the subscription, you get 1000-speed
credits that allow you to jump to the top
of the queue.
Even more, users with the subscription can
also download their own creation with the
Basic POD license.
So, what are you waiting for?
Check out Creative Fabrica by using our affiliate
link shown on the screen and in the video
description below and start creating art from
just text descriptions.
Okay, it’s still 2022 and if we think about
image generation, we are not thinking of GANs
anymore, but of diffusion models such as DALL-E
2 or Stable Diffusion, Imagen and so on.
For more details on diffusion models, check
out our previous videos.
Or we are thinking of transformer-based image
generation such as DALL-E 1.
The outputs of these models are amazing, but
they come at a computational cost.
Diffusion models take hundreds of sampling
steps – so of inference steps of the same
U-Net neural network – to gradually paint
structure from noise.
So diffusion models take a long time to produce
an image for the end user.
Transformer based image generators have two
problems: As transformers usually work with
sets of vectors, one must project the two-dimensional
images into vectors.
One should not use too many vectors as a representation
of each image, since the computation time
grows quadratically with the numbers of vectors,
so with the sequence length, due to the self-attention
layers
To generate an image, transformers generate
one such image vector at a time, which takes
a while.
For more details on generating not images,
but videos with transformers, check out our
previous video on Phenaki that generates endless
videos with transformers.
But this paper, proposes Paella, which employs
another way to generate images from text without
diffusion, without transformers, but with
just good old convolutional neural networks,
or CNNs in short.
How does it do it, then?
The authors do the following: They take the
image and use a VQ-GAN to represent the image
in a lower-dimensional space.
A VQ-what?
Don’t worry Ms. Coffee Bean, we’ll explain
the VQGAN in a nutshell.
The main idea of a VQ-GAN is to take the image,
run it through an encoder neural network,
in this case CNN-based, to represent it in
a lower dimensional space.
You are correct to be reminded of the Latent
Diffusion models, because this is a trick
they employ there too.
Then a decoder neural network, also CNN-based
in this case, takes in the lower dimensional
representation and reconstructs the image.
The encoder and decoder are trained together
in this image reconstruction setting.
Now what about the quantization part?
Well, without quantization, the latent representation
of images would be dense, and all possible
representations are allowed as long as they
are vectors in this lower dimensional space.
In this example, our latent space is two dimensional
and the x-es stand each for a different image.
But a VQGAN says no: Let’s not learn any
embedding, let’s just map everything to
a learned codebook of a given size.
If the encoder says that this picture lands
around here, the quantization step takes the
nearest vector from the learned codebook,
here in red and assigns it as a representation
for this image, which we call a codeword.
In this way, the decoder does not need to
reconstruct from any vector in the space,
but only from the codebook vectors, which
act like the centroids of the data.
You can think of the VQGAN as of an autoencoder
that also learns to cluster the data with
nearest neighbors.
In the training procedure of the VQGAN, the
objective is to reconstruct images.
To successfully do so, we learn the encoder
weights, the decoder weights and what the
optimal entries of this codebook are.
So, for an image in three channels of 256x256,
the authors learn a codeword sized 32x32x256,
so they represent an image which is a stack
of three larger matrices as a stack of 256
smaller 32x32 matrices.
Now we have a way to represent each image
in a learned codebook, so in a meaningful
lower dimensional representation.
How to generate images from text using this
codebook?
The authors take the codeword of an image
and noise out a fraction f of the 256 small
matrices, so image tokens representing it.
Noising means that they are taking another
random codeword from the codebook to replace
it.
In other words, they use the centroid of another
image token cluster.
Then they send the noised representation to
Paella for denoising.
Paella is CNN-based and not transformer-based
like prior work.
This has the advantage of being more runtime
efficient and can work with larger inputs,
therefore the compression into the codebook
does not have to be that stark, so important
details from the image can be kept.
Paella takes the noised representation, the
number of steps and a condition to denoise
the latent representation.
You have one guess for what this condition
is:
Of course, it is a text representation, coming
from CLIP embeddings.
Of course, it could be anything, like class
labels or semantic segmentation maps.
But to do text-conditioned image generation,
the authors take the text, run it through
CLIP’s text branch to get a text representation
and Paella learns through cross-entropy and
classifier-free guidance to reproduce the
uncorrupted codewords of the image.
If you want to know what classifier free guidance
is, check out our previous video.
The reconstructed latent space representation
can run through the decoder.
And so, at the decoder output, we have an
image conditioned on text.
During inference, to produce an image from
just text, Paella takes a codeword of just
noise.
It could try to denoise everything at once,
but during training, it has never encountered
the case of total noise in the input, so it
would do quite badly.
Therefore, it denoises the codeword in a sequence
of 8 steps (hm, how diffusion-like, but it
is actually more similar with masked language
modelling).
At each step, the authors denoise everything,
but randomly renoise tokens again to give
the model a chance to denoise these based
on the already predicted tokens.
If you think this is very much like MaskGIT
in Phenaki, you are right.
The difference here is that the authors do
not use MASK tokens, but random tokens.
Because here at inference we are still in
the latent space, the decoder reconstructs
the pixel space of the represented image.
This was Paella in a nutshell.
Since Paella only contains convolutions and
no transformers and other things, it can do
latent space interpolation, inpaint images
(so imagine what a hole in an image might
be filled with) or do structural editing.
The authors trained it on 600 million images
from the improved LAION-5B aesthetic (like
StableDiffusion) on 64 NVIDIA A100 for two
weeks – with support from Stability AI,
for sure.
You can judge for yourself what you think
of the generations or look at the author’s
FID metrics, which you know, are not always
aligned to what humans think is a good image.
Maybe these generations are not what you saw
from carefully prompted diffusion models,
but keep in mind that Paella is relatively
small in terms of numbers of parameters compared
to existing diffusion models, need way less
sampling steps
and takes half a second to generate an image.
The authors provide all model weights of Paella,
together with a pytorch-based implementation
in their github repository.
They even have a Google Colab and are on Huggingface
spaces.
So do check them out.
Now, we are leaving you with Paellas version
of “The cutest coffee bean there is.”
and hope to see you next time!
Okay, bye!